and uh you mentioned uh nakamura briefly
uh about one year ago uh the chess pro
youtube channel received the copyright
strike from uh multi-channel network
acting on his behalf and can you tell us
what happened and what's your
relationship
with nakamura today um
yeah so i i would like to say i know
exactly what happened but some of it's
like you know
what's people saying you can't fully
verify the the origin but uh
um we we got a strike
but
it was
from the multi-channel network but
directed from his team to do so
carlos team told the multi-channel
network or the
channel management to to enforce it
um
just you know
didn't like some of the the matches
that maybe showcased
hikaru in an unflattering manner
anything like that
wasn't uh
wasn't welcome
was the you know
what what i heard um
and i haven't haven't been in any
discussions or i don't really have an
update since since about a year ago
um
it's like the whole whole topic you
could almost make a movie about or
something because you have these
anonymous people you know we're working
behind the scenes so i don't i don't
have all the answers but um
i mean
nothing's really been fixed in certain
aspects so
um yeah
i mean
i'd like to avoid those those situations
so i mean we're not we're we're not
trying to there's there's been nothing
new in that and that hasn't gotten worse
hasn't gotten better just there's that
incident
and um
was there a physical confrontation at
some point did you get in a fight
uh the physical confrontation at least
didn't have to do with those things it
was like that was a few years ago at the
u.s championships
but
yeah that was unrelated to uh
to um
to the copyright strikes
[Music]
but yeah no there's there's been there's
been a bit of uh lawn wrestling you
could say
um which is actually like the
we actually like to do that chess frog
parties with friends like we love well
not striking but like wrestling like
do that all the time and he started his
kids doing that like amman and some
other buddies we would always like just
like just even as kids like wrestling
like not no hard feelings just like
yeah just for fun maybe i watch too much
wrestling uh as a kid because i did
watch a lot but is that how it started
with hikaru
it didn't start like that um
it didn't start like that uh if it did
it'd probably be a bit different but um
i can't say he's on my you know i don't
think i'm on his like friendly wrestling
list or something or just uh
want to
tackle
tackle each other but um yeah the
there's been a physical confrontation uh
but that was uh
before this yeah copyrighted but it
seems like